you know what the [ __ ] going on in
stanford vegas i'm gonna have a wire
beat ted's bootleg cab on the bootleg
cab podcast y'all check it out
yo boulet cav show man special guest in
here uh my guys thunderful vegas is here
welcome yes sir family bootleg
hey man uh you brought you brought
someone with you man i'ma let you
introduce your your guy here i bought yb
test my right hand man my brother my
first artist
i'm gonna pop some [ __ ] off call welcome
to four vegas records real soon so you
got your own label
yeah oh yeah it's in the works so uh and
this is your first artist yes sir where
are you from man i fell morrow north
carolina but it got down i started
everything i got them built in canapes
north carolina so north carolina keeping
it keeping it at home base man i got i
got also like five other artists who amo
oh [ __ ] i'm gonna put like i'm gonna do
it different though okay watch i'm gonna
do it different from everybody like i
got far more artists that's all from
north carolina different like parts
got crazy motion in the carolinas you
feel me just ain't got that light [ __ ]
on right right right uh what did you
learn because obviously
you getting kind of you know brought
into the game by baby with billion
dollar baby entertainment what are the
things that you kind of have taken from
what he does as a ceo
that you're applying to your own label
advice for show cause we already like
the same age all of us maybe way older
than you know but we already like not
way over me just like five years but you
feel me yeah he got
a little bit more yeah he got a jump
starter in life than yeah
so he like when i met him
i always say that to when i met bruh
like he taught me a lot of [ __ ] that
i was like damn i told him like well i
just needed the older brother right
right right around me and what we had
going on already we [ __ ] around being
some of the biggest rappers in north
carolina six years ago i'll tell you
[ __ ] but
i wasn't rapping there we were just
doing a lot of [ __ ] living like rappers
too and like
like when i met baby he was like um
like yeah man i seen y'all look out now
vlogs and [ __ ] right right
because originally forensic trucks and
[ __ ] you originally like got him for one
of your records i guess
yeah and he just respected the way you
moved and the way you were doing things
so much that he was like yo let's work
right yeah it was just like let's work
first it wasn't anything i'm assigned it
was less work but baby so
like about this business it probably was
i'm assigning first from the jump but he
was like it was also like he was trying
to figure me out yeah he was trying to
like i know like you feel me like trying
to get to know me trying to make sure
like we can do this and do business
first because we probably hung out like
probably a month straight first for sure
before i just signed
yeah how's um you know with the pandemic
and everything uh finally feeling like
it's i mean i saw you was doing shows
throughout the whole [ __ ] in the south
you know what i'm saying a lot of texas
shows like back to back to texas
coupling um
where else we go during the pandemic
it was just texas texas was why the [ __ ]
opened it wasn't just texas
atlanta for sure atlanta was wide the
[ __ ] open atlanta
i feel like we were shooting a lot of
music videos and features in atlanta but
we really was a low-key i probably did
like four shows like four months
straight too yeah came back next month
came back next month to dallas sold out
every time
yeah no i feel like um i saw you was
just a lot of people were kind of
[ __ ] during the pandemic because they
did they didn't have that following in a
lot of those states but i feel like i
saw i still saw you doing shows still
working for sure i'm gonna figure it out
though i'm adapt
i'm gonna dab so besides you launching
the label uh i hear your debut albums
coming because everything are we
considering everything else you've
dropped knicks tapes for the show so
this next project is like the official
album we going to debut for sure i'ma
make sure that it don't sound like
none of the mixtapes you feel me i'ma
make sure
like that [ __ ] know that i'm
versatile for show for show like it's
gonna be different sound and music on
there
i got like [ __ ] that i already got that
i don't put on there but i'll probably
like record all new music like
for sure like new songs with baby for
sure i'm not putting no old feature on
there
i'm just going we're gonna do some new
[ __ ] for sure and drop everything i got
old with them i'm just gonna drop it for
my fan like
youtube or whatever like if he won't i
will like [ __ ] like just throw it out
it's like a little joint ap or something
[ __ ] so why not i'm on youtube i'm about
to give it to him for the show i mean
instagram's down right now so you might
only have youtube i don't know what the
[ __ ] going on for sure but oh
[ __ ] like
for sure we're gonna go debut um top of
the year you have the name yet no not
yet not yet
but we like brainstorming every day
me and
shout out to kia at sc
so i'm beating b though yeah but kia
like she be got down
helping me do a lot of creativity [ __ ]
right right
just extra ideas that
fit me for your definitely got now as i
say for your label are you gonna um are
you gonna do like a compilation or
something the kind of interesting i was
gonna say that i'm gonna do the
compilation probably before the album so
that's gonna come first indie
drop it independently yeah that's so
wing going i ain't trying to even
feel me that's smart
but show like i'ma tell you though like
some real [ __ ]
like boom shout out like i say why be
ted's get rich zay cocaine mali boss
flip banner prince glock boy keys all
these artists that i'm naming
they do views that
artist is signing like ain't doing and
these are artists that are going to be
on your label yeah these these young
[ __ ] ain't
they just damn rapping right right and
the label is called stunner world what
is no one's gonna be welcome to foe
vegas welcome to phoebe and that was my
last mixtape but i wanted that to be an
album too i wanted to do that bigger
than i did it right but
feel me
well everything is a lesson you feel me
so like i say we're gonna that's gonna
be the album
name two for the compilation
it might be like a throw off on it or
something but yeah that's going to be
the weapon of vegas records for sure
it's crazy because you um
talk how did you guys end up
having jake paul pull up to the video
because we ran into him in hollywood
somewhere because was this right after
he knocked nick robinson out right yeah
it was like right after that so this is
before jake paul was like i mean he was
popping jake paul has always been
popping
but i feel like he's in a different
spectrum of like being a serious boxer
now so like yeah talk about how that
happened so you ran into him we ran into
him in hollywood and that's probably why
but jake like he he likes solid i ain't
gonna lala i ain't even gonna put no
offense he's like you know he had to do
that little [ __ ] he did like right i
mean
it's like
it helps a win we helped him he ain't
really have to do it
to me but it was a win-win at the same
time he got to meet the baby play music
of course they probably nobody ever
heard
that [ __ ] can rap too for sure
like you're telling me jake paul can rap
how about
i vouch
it's good the music is good how about
she played us three songs that i was
like
really
and they're not in my head for sure i
ain't gonna lie to you like would you do
the jake paul feature
are you you go yeah but i fought with
jay paul so i would tell him like
like just take like life just a little
bit more serious you feel me
so if he hit you are you charging him or
you just gonna do it because it's mutual
i'm gonna do it when he charged us to do
like for no little appearance or nothing
he came and thug all day
he thugging with us all day
all day i think we went to the club
damn jake paul's got good music huh man
he played three good songs for sure i am
not i wonder if he's writing his own
[ __ ]
i only won't get to go in there but no
way there's no way he's writing his [ __ ]
i definitely do you know [ __ ] with jake
no no i just don't i j no i respect him
i just don't think he's writing his own
music
i don't know all these i met a lot of
artists though they don't write those
[ __ ] for sure of course no i didn't even
know that [ __ ] was going on if you're a
youtuber you should pay somebody to
write your [ __ ] for sure you know
because if you want to be taken serious
you just can't assume your shit's high
pay somebody who knows what they're
doing
he played a song i would like boy draco
hop on this [ __ ]
that's crazy
i know he has a record with gucci mane
that's a few years old that he bagged
gucci out for
and this song was terrible there's a
gucci mane jake paul song that's like i
think it came out like 2018 or 2019.
that's crazy he probably always wanted
to be a rapper probably i mean i feel
like everyone right at some point in
time
[Music]
everybody
even everybody even but hey like a [ __ ]
act like oh man [ __ ] that rap [ __ ] i
don't need like he want them to be the
biggest ones
yeah they be the ones that wish they was
in
little baby or the baby's shoes
a hundred percent man 100
what was it like
kind of witnessing what happened with
baby the last few months because you
know obviously rolling loud happened i
was there you know uh but what was that
like kind of just witnessing like
people trying to cancel them and and and
just that whole situation was crazy
it seems like he's on the other side of
it now thank god i think it was nothing
small to a giant like
just a lesson not everyone's built to
yeah everybody wouldn't go through that
and make it out on the other side
a lot of your favorite rappers might
have stopped rapping deleted their
instagram
facts or had a mental breakdown or some
[ __ ] or
start tripping
whatever i don't know probably though no
no i mean i feel like he's in good
spirits and i feel like like you said
man everything's a learning experience
right
and i know he's got some crazy music
that's got to be on the way because the
wayne record is crazy
you gotta have some [ __ ] how's um
for you like
did you learn anything that you could
apply to like your [ __ ] off of what
happened with him
no
like you mean like did it affect me
no i mean like did you see kind of see
what happened and kind of like you know
did you learn anything from it that you
could apply to your own [ __ ] oh for sure
yeah so i learned off everything else
like i learned on
like my mistakes i learned off i i
literally like a watch somebody else
make a mistake and try to like oh i
gotta yeah
yeah
i gotta go that way because that that
way wasn't it like i'm off my own
mistakes too though
but i ain't really see that as nothing
wrong but i just you feel me like
you know
this [ __ ] is what it is yeah but you see
how
he stepped on top of that nah for sure
um
i know that
what's dope about
what arnold's done what baby's done and
now what you're doing is keeping
everything within the carolinas
show which is amazing because
i feel like prior to baby
there really wasn't a nap there was a
scene there but there wasn't nationally
a face nope shout out to cold off a show
but it wasn't nobody like
i just nobody that's making
[ __ ] want to kind of like i go
everywhere
i feel like in the same way that like
eminem is the face of detroit for so
long but eminem didn't really like
there was so much more to detroit that
we didn't know about we didn't know
about it and the same thing would cause
shoulders yeah but cold cold like
obviously put on for fayetteville and
but i just feel like charlotte is such
an important city that there's such a
thriving local scene and
i fought with
he probably definitely should have
him and baby should have worked a long
time ago like i mean you know i feel
like he tapped into like a semi early
when when baby started to take off and
put him on revenge of the dreamers i
mean it was i was kind of late but it
was and it was a feature
with other people now i respect that
song too hard but now there's more ray
who's doing his thing shout out to moray
he's going crazy but just in general is
he signing
no he's signed to um the homie mo uh
schalizzi and uh
big six records
but yeah but you know i feel like
carolinas right now are like definitely
on the come up man but how important is
it for you guys like i know it's always
a big deal for arnold and baby to put on
for the for the city but for you for
your label like did you make a conscious
decision to be like yo i'm gonna put on
artists from here first
because you probably could have signed
anybody from anywhere else for sure for
sure
like to this day for sure like now that
artists be seeing me do it like artists
that's
getting posted on say cheese and all
that every day they'd be like in my dm's
like what's up with it bro like right
come snatch me up i like but i'll be
like [ __ ] i owe it to them first i
really felt like it was supposed to
happen when i came in but i was trying
to focus on at least stamping my name
first at the same time
but um
it's like important to me too because
i feel like
because of what we'd be like rapping
about this [ __ ] like or how we be coming
into music [ __ ] be like
oh man we don't want to listen to that
but [ __ ] that's what [ __ ] really come
from sometimes like that's how [ __ ] go
in the studio and feel like that's if
that's what they feel like
one thing i also feel like is boom you
can't really like
you take all criticism but you can't
really like let a [ __ ] tell you
bro stop rapping about all that shoot
them up bang bang right just stop it bro
like
cause boom
use
boom
bruh [ __ ] simple [ __ ] simple
[ __ ] tell you
stop to shoot him up bang bang [ __ ]
one of the biggest artists to pop this
year is push ice free push feisty free
push action yeah and it ain't like it
wasn't a gimmick well i was going to say
is there a lesson to be learned because
i do feel like
rappers are more targets now than ever
when it comes to the feds the show okay
boom this is another thing though
it's not like
i ain't saying
get on the song say you killed this man
killed this man i have never even
came that crazy on those songs i don't
tell you [ __ ] names
get on the internet
do nothing crazy like right i probably
have once and it ain't go but i don't do
all that [ __ ] because i'm not even like
i ain't get big off that like i know
once you start doing all that extra gay
ass internet [ __ ] because you not in a
[ __ ] face
your fans gonna expect that all the time
yeah
boy you as a rapper you gonna have to go
you're carrying that energy with you
every show you got you know whatever
city you win man they gonna tell that
you better be that's how you carry
yourself bro they gonna test you
wherever wherever you go you better be
but
like
man
it's like
like i say you ain't gotta get on that
[ __ ] and say the crazy [ __ ] but
like rap however you want to wreak your
truth yeah yeah
go however you want to go with that hoe
if it's hard it's hard [ __ ]
can't deny if it's hard right so
i would say yeah
but if you versatile 2b versus uh i
ain't trying to say let's all rap shoot
them up baby boom boom but i'm telling
like the young [ __ ] from north
carolina basically everybody that i'm
working with is kind of on it
and
it's not like it ain't like
it's like gimmicks do you feel like the
carolinas are like as a scene like
are most of the artists united now
not yet
is it getting there because it feels
like everybody's pretty much under like
arnold's umbrella in some capacity like
you got
under the baby he's under you know it
just feels like this yeah but it'll take
some
carolina [ __ ] to really go down though
like oh all of us really get around each
other like
and ain't nothing wrong with like
separation but i'm saying like we don't
really
like we don't really
all be around each other like that but
everybody is busy too you feel me like
but it feels like because i feel like
there's some cities in hip-hop right now
where we feel like
jacksonville every i feel like everyone
in jackson was trying to kill each other
jacksonville trying to kill those
[ __ ] insane that's why they going i
need a lot they going up
i [ __ ] with some jacksonville artists
too but they're going up
because ace and julio up here like it's
going crazy though it's like you know
like
it's it's to the point where it's like
yo y'all gotta get the [ __ ] under
control because like yeah everybody's
gonna end up [ __ ] dead and there's no
like what no one can get money if y'all
ain't here
and i feel like with carolina i don't
feel that energy i feel like there's at
least some sort of unification it's
definitely that in north carolina though
i i keep it all the way
real right it's it's damn near
jacksonville it can't be that and not in
just charlotte it can be like that in
charlotte and salisbury where i'm from
in kannapolis where he from and durham
will get rich zayn right other artists i
was telling you from um
in raleigh where cocaine alley be it
type [ __ ] like it can get like that
everywhere in north carolina like
i'm wondering being from north carolina
when you were growing up
was little brother ever on your radar
fonte and big poo
do you know who they are no
oh okay little brother was like uh was
one of the hardest rap groups ever it's
fonte bigpool they're on atlanta
yeah they're from raleigh during north
carolina yeah oh yeah little brother i
ain't gonna lie shout out them though
you gotta tap in with font hey man fonte
is a cold man damn bro like some of the
biggest artists
one of drake's biggest influences in
like as a rapper
okay go back just little brothers
no
i'm gonna definitely patch in for sure
they were popping in like 2005 2006
there's some i ain't even just trying to
like you feel me like i ain't the one
with the big head i don't care about
this [ __ ] that much it came back i think
after pete like when did peter pablo pop
off when i was i was a kid so it was
after petey pablo he damn sure went in
2005.
we was like probably on like
gucci mane slim dunk
that's what i'm saying yeah p pablo man
shout out to him
shout out to pete pablo too i think we
got now had a conversation before
someone should redo the uh raise up [ __ ]
i was thinking about it just why not
throw it out there on worldstar see what
it does if it starts popping you know we
might we might do it and throw it on our
jump how [ __ ] petey hop on you know
petey has some [ __ ] man yeah you know he
had a rat this crazy because he was
signing timberland and he was signed to
death row that [ __ ] has a very
underrated rap career like
he's probably from me it's because he
come from like from north carolina like
the carolina's still kind of slept on
like even if it's kind of looking like
yeah it's not
like you feel me just because i just
named five artists right right that i
feel definitely has the potential to be
just as big as me to see right right the
baby like for sure hey what up man we
gotta interrupt the interview real quick
to tell you about our family at odd
socks now when i be riding for oddssox
so hard man it's because i really love
the product they got the most
comfortable socks in the [ __ ] world i
got a pair of odd socks basics on right
now go get those they got the socks wwe
joints you know i'm saying shout out to
the undertaker pepsi [ __ ]
really whatever you need some weed socks
nickelodeon but really they got the
draws now ladies and gentlemen
i'm holding a pair of tapatio underwear
right now
you want some pop tarts on your dick pop
tart draws and these [ __ ] are
so comfortable
like
man so listen you gotta go to
oddssoxofficial.com
and use the uh promo code the discount
code bootleg kev
at oddsoxofficial.com you'll save 20 off
underwear the most comfortable socks in
the world crazy licenses not only they
got the ww they got the scarface they
got the street fighter they got the
nickelodeon they got it all so make sure
you hit that website oddsoxofficial.com
save 20 off with the promo code bootleg
kev all right go do that shout out to
odd socks let's get back to the
interview um i know you just also got
into the weed [ __ ] a bit right for sure
shout out man
cause i just so much i'm high right now
we just dropped no we haven't dropped
yet okay in stores but we yeah we had a
little pop-ups and [ __ ] the big 41
gelato
type [ __ ] when you get like uh
how do you talk about lavender boys how
do you choose your
strain is it like yo this is the kind of
[ __ ] i smoke so it's got to be the kind
of [ __ ] i would smoke
because you say it's a gelato yeah like
july like i do like gelatos but like but
yeah that's how it's got to be for sure
plus it's i think gelato you know like i
feel like og's are like what i like to
smoke but og's ain't selling like that
because it's kind of like it is though
but maybe not out here oh geez it's not
like
when we think of like weed like
it's not like an exotic flavor
you know everybody wants skit they want
someone a crazy name you know what i'm
saying yo you got some of them runts
some of them skittles some of that some
of that za like nah i got some og though
this is the small og every day though no
oh geez my [ __ ] i love og
gelato i feel like you know probably
more um
financially smart to go with
shout out to uh so it's what's it called
it's big 41 gelato big 41 gelato
it's all good man but um
bro that it's crazy i don't have nothing
like
i got a picture or something she can't
pull up instagram right now ah
somebody just takes me like damn brother
g [ __ ] we let's see if it's back
it's been down for like i know it's
still done the [ __ ] damn man i ain't got
nothing but
bro if they really deleted [ __ ]
instagram
yeah
he's hanging to see who got them
built the last
that's crazy are you like now that
you're kind of like you know doing well
financially are you doing anything like
smart with your money are you doing any
like real estate or you're moving your
bread around or not yet but like i'm i'm
on like
i'll be like
i'll tell myself i'm about to do this
i'll tell myself i'm about to do 10
things but like nothing get done if i
don't just focus on one thing you got
80d
did you have it like did they tell you
you had a d as a kid yeah i used to got
them
[ __ ] you try to tell my mama put
me on medicine and [ __ ] but she ain't
never done that's about to say thank god
she didn't that's just terrible
what is it what is that medicine
everyone does foreign
ritalin right adderall ritalin and [ __ ]
i used to see a [ __ ] that used to be
just like me too bro when they put that
[ __ ] uh i ain't gonna say his name but
i'm gonna tell you what i'm talking
about you're gonna know
they put my boy on that written oh
pissed off
my [ __ ]
my [ __ ] has to be
bro i heard but what's crazy is
the other day me and him got down
you feel me like i'm like down i heard
that like adderall is supposed to be
like uh
you do adderall that's just like doing
meth
i heard you do add a wall you get
everything done in the day you need to
get done
like people who edit video and engineers
who mix and master
most of them are they'll they're on
adderall because that's how they get
you know you papa addy and you [ __ ]
just edit a whole music video in an hour
you know what i'm saying
man i don't doubt it man
i just keep [ __ ] real [ __ ] i seen that
[ __ ] busy say like [ __ ] like
he was like [ __ ] i'm charging 20k for
my for my uh interviews because [ __ ]
won't see what i'm saying i keep [ __ ]
real
i remember like a lot i did an interview
once upon a time [ __ ] like
certain [ __ ] shout out to satan
and not baby like nobody right around me
personally
but [ __ ] are gonna say like man
you do like some interview coaching man
like baby
i feel like the [ __ ] interview coach
i feel like when you first
came by
by yourself i ain't gonna lie i ain't
camping by myself no you haven't no no
no no you came up to the station we
interviewed you solo and we lost the
footage it never came out but baby was
chilling in the lobby he pulled up just
to say what up but we interviewed you
solo it was for um
yeah you came up solo and baby just
popped up he's like yo i'm in the
neighborhood i gotta come through show
love you know but he didn't come in on
the interview at all but i feel like you
have gotten better because i feel like
there was a point in time
where you weren't
comfortable talking your [ __ ] yet that
makes sense it wasn't even that it was
like
i was new to that [ __ ] bro like i was
like i was
i was like just new to the [ __ ] to where
like
boom you know i stopped probably
dropping stop dropping music and all
that [ __ ] i had a life i really to
myself straight up like i want to like
fall back
for music for a minute like just pay
attention to everything that's going on
pay attention to all these rappers that
was hit me up
every day yeah i love you brother
gay ass [ __ ] right i ain't mad about it
either right i'm just keeping it real
like watch how them [ __ ] you feel me
just watch how all this [ __ ] play out
after a bunch of [ __ ] having your family
[ __ ] count you all this [ __ ]
just watch how this [ __ ] play off
and but like boom long story short what
i was really trying to say is
when i first got in that [ __ ] i'm like
boom
like
maybe i should like play this like label
[ __ ] like pl
try to listen to [ __ ] like
actually for one time like
and it was just like
like that she would probably like more i
ain't a lot when i used to do interviews
i used to like i'm in the car like
um well
how should i say it like but also
because i don't like want to say the
wrong thing or nothing yeah or whatever
but like i got to the point well back to
the point because that's why i really
was before i signed the deal just don't
give a [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] that's
what it real like in real life bro do
not but they should pay the bills and
take care of my mama so we go
i love this [ __ ] i don't take this [ __ ]
for granted but i don't care like that
impressed
like you feel me yeah i ain't here for
the popularity you know what it is it's
like
if
it ain't mutual
in genuine relationships like boom i'm
doing the same thing you doing right i
don't look at no man like he's bigger
than me i don't care about no money no
budget
nothing you feel me like we all the same
it's a real deal we get up in front of
each other [ __ ] right right
you don't think a [ __ ] was on it you
ain't never seen
but
like
i was for sure though like you said when
i was up here i was like uncomfortable
like i was like damn maybe i shouldn't
that [ __ ] happens hey honestly that [ __ ]
has happened a lot where like i'll have
i'll know someone and they'll come on on
the show and and they're like like timid
or whatever or they're not used to
yeah i wasn't timid i was just like them
i don't know what that was like we had i
think we're telling them too much like
we have
some [ __ ]
we had a key glock on the show a couple
years ago and i'm not spoken with key
glock off camera a lot and he came on
the show and it was like
like why are you even here
because he was not trained like he ain't
doing the interviews like that i just
talked to dolph about that too i was
like hey bro bring glock on the show but
make sure this time he actually [ __ ]
talks like you know what i'm saying but
yeah i do i think i did interviews
though like i did more interviews you
could really like
real deal go look at interviews i did
before i was assigned to baby
and i was
just you feeling me like
off the wall raw talent yeah yeah it
wasn't trained it wasn't i think that's
what people like tell people that
that you didn't have like right we all
went through that same [ __ ] for sure i'm
trying to
come in here with that store mm-hmm so
when is the compilation is it is it done
or is it when's it dropped it's durable
but we're gonna probably drop top of the
year top of the year top of the new year
my birthday january first to anybody
that feel like they're a real friend you
feel me drop drop something on the cash
out [ __ ] what a [ __ ] come with the
artist whatever you feel me and you and
baby how many records you think you and
baby got in the stash right now plenty
i'm dropping them all plenty too many i
just told him that today he like let's
lock in this week like i bet i'm like
i'm trying to drop
that's not a throw away like me and baby
they'll do some crazy [ __ ] and
they don't got a hook
so baby say it's a throw away but but
like
baby will also be telling me like boom
boy
like you're gonna say baby also like
prior didn't be a superstar a lot of my
favorite songs of his didn't have hooks
it'd be like a minute and like 20
seconds longer just like going crazy
yeah from the from the start to the
finish of the beat facts like
one of the biggest songs that me and him
did to being all the baby freestyle the
fan freestyle right out the animal yeah
and animal only had a hook because of
baby like i didn't do a hook ah he said
hey bro just go back in and like do that
[ __ ] for him and then i'm going to kill
that i said all right
he like boom after his verse he's like
tell the engineer put that [ __ ] right
and he like this is how you supposed to
be rapping like
but
cuz all my songs that he told me that
was fire was like just me starting to
finish crazy
start to finish no hood nothing but he
like this how you make a song like this
how you
uh he started teaching me [ __ ] early you
feel me we wouldn't even
no paperwork yet like that why i also
signed a baby because i knew that [ __ ]
was genuine yeah because he was [ __ ]
with you before you guys had anything in
any of the ink dried yeah hey
well look the compilation coming
compilation coming i'm coming to wii is
here
this is not here it's not here though
but yeah it's here for sure it's here
you can come get it it's just in your
lungs right now if you dm one big 41
gelato on instagram right now
you know yeah you know
you can get it good luck good luck on
instagram right now oh [ __ ]
hopefully hey hopefully by the time this
comes out everything's fixed it should
be now look though this million dollar
company want to focus on being not a
baby being not a baby
and welcome to fall vegas
i need when we get instagram back going
or [ __ ] instagram just get on youtube
right now
whenever this drop y'all see this
and go comment if you see this you gonna
comment on one of the videos
from y r b test
y r b space t e
z z
no two z's
get rich say that's all together boss
flip that's all together b.o.s flip
cocaine maui
space between that you go to my youtube
standard for vegas everybody got [ __ ] on
there subscribe go pay attention
and then go do some dna some research on
every artist i told you about
and it might shock you there it is [ __ ]
probably really about
[Music]
becoming one of the hardest labels
well there it is
hey man standing for vegas appreciate
y'all pulling up man i for sure
appreciate you for having me boom